hi everyone my name is sai venom with
the IBM cloud team today we want to talk
about managed kubernetes kubernetes is
an open source platform allowing you to
run your containerized workloads manage
kubernetes on the other hand is a
service provided by cloud providers and
comes with a number of advantages for
one it's very easy to spin up new
kubernetes clusters from scratch and add
additional compute power in response to
load in addition it allows you to
integrate with cutting-edge open source
capabilities as well as familiar cloud
provider services finally you get peace
of mind with security across the board
let's go through an example of spinning
up a kubernetes cluster on IBM cloud
kubernetes service first we'll choose
the name for the cluster as well as the
region that we want to spin it up in we
can drill in deeper and choose the exact
data center that we want our cluster to
live in in addition we can also choose a
multi zone cluster this allows us to
spread our kubernetes cluster across
multiple data centers in the same region
this gives us high availability if
anything went wrong with one of the data
centers next we can choose the flavor
for the compute power for this
kubernetes cluster we can stick with
virtual compute or even bare-metal
bare-metal allows you to get dedicated
access to the entire machine allowing
you to avoid that noisy neighbor issue
next you can even define GPUs for your
compute power in case you had something
like machine learning or image or video
processing that can take advantage of
GPUs finally scrolling down to the
bottom we can choose a number of worker
nodes that we want to spin up and go
ahead and create that cluster in a few
minutes your kubernetes cluster will be
provisioned and ready to use kubernetes
is an open source platform and it's part
of the cloud native computing foundation
to ensure portability of your workloads
across any kubernetes service provider
the C&C F provides conformance testing
this enables you to avoid vendor lock-in
and even allows you to do multi cloud
deployments of your kubernetes based
applications here at IBM were strong
proponents of open standards as well as
projects in the open source community
these include those in the CNC F as well
as projects like Sto
okay native in fact you could try and
manage sto and manage K native today on
IBM cloud kubernetes service outside of
those managed offerings we also offer
tutorials and documentation to integrate
with cutting-edge open source
capabilities as well as IBM tooling and
offerings finally let's talk about
security security is something that
should be integrated into every stage of
your DevOps workflow with IBM cloud
kubernetes service will make sure you're
protected every step of the way first
we have trusted private registries that
scan your images for any vulnerabilities
second we'll make sure that those images
are scanned as they're being pushed into
a kubernetes cluster behind the scenes
we're always making sure that any
vulnerabilities in the technology stack
the powers your cluster are caught right
away thanks for watching this quick
overview of managed kubernetes services
if you like this video or have any
questions be sure to drop a comment
below stay tuned for more videos like
this in the future and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe